welcome to yet another addition to a
Python playlist by simply learn I'm
Angela and today we'll be covering all
the basic concepts of Python followed by
some of the libraries which are very
essential when you learn Python so we'll
start right from printing your hello
world which is the most basic program
whenever you learn a programming
language up to even implementing one of
the machine learning algorithms through
simple code and utilizing a Python
library to do so so this tutorial starts
from the very basic even if you are
completely new to Python and have a
basic understanding of any other
programming language this should be
quite helpful for you so let's begin now
as I mentioned previously a first
program would be to print out hello
world like we always do now advise and
whenever you want to print out the
string a number or anything as such you
use this print function it's very much
similar to print F or C out whichever
language you prefer to use so you just
say print open brackets and since it's a
string I put them within double quotes
and in here just type out hello world
and just run this line and as you see
here hello world is printed out now
another very cool thing that you can do
with Python is you can print a string
out any number of times without actually
having to repeat it so if I want to
print out hello world ten times I do not
need to type it ten times rather I can
just do this so just like before put in
hello world within double quotes and
then you just say into ten now when you
see this as you can see here helloworld
has been printed out ten times now of
course this is not done right because
world and hello are put in together
so just put double spaces after world
run this again and as you can see hello
world is printed out ten times now
obviously when you're programming this
kind of a thing doesn't really come in
use but it's nice to know that you can
do something of this sort now the next
thing we'll be covering here is
variables so variables as you probably
already know is a pox which basically
stores a value now this variable can
store an integer type of value it can
store a string a float or any other type
and python is dynamically typed so what
this means is unlike in Java or any
other program
language where you have to actually
mention the type of value that the
variable holds at the time of creation
of the variable in peyten
you do not need to do that so you can
just have any variable same message
don't specify its type just assign it a
value so over here I am going to assign
my variable the value hello world now
when you save this and run your code
Piketon automatically understands that
this value is a string and that is what
is being assigned to this variable so
now to print out the value of the
variable you just say print and put in
the variable name so guys please notice
here that initially when we had to print
out the string we put them in double
quotes here we are not putting the
variable name in double quotes so this
is because we do not need to print out
the variable name if I put out message
in double quotes
it will literally print out message but
what I want to print out is the value
that is stored in message so want to
print out the value of a variable just
put in the variable name without any
codes now I'll run this program and as
you see hello world is printed over here
which is the value stored in a variable
so that is a basic on how variables work
we'll explore this further as we cover
other concepts so in a second program
we'll be creating a very basic
calculator which will preform addition
subtraction multiplication division and
find the remainder so here first we look
into how numbers work in Python so just
like any other programming language or
in fact just like in math numbers
basically can be integers or it can be
floating-point numbers so integers are
whole numbers like 1 2 3 4 and
floating-point numbers are the ones with
digits after your decimal point so
that's two point three eight and five
point six three and so on so here what
we'll do is we'll first taken two values
from the user store them into a variable
and then perform different operations on
these values again the operation
performed on the value will also be a
choice which will be given by the user
so let's begin coding so let's take in
our first value from the user and to
take an input from the user
Python uses a function called input now
within this function you can pass a
message
which will be displayed to the user
basically instructing the user as in
what he or she has to input so we've
only first digit for our operation so we
say enter the first number and that now
input function returns the value which
is given by the user so that will be
stored in a variable a now we need
another number from the user which will
be a second number so I'll just copy
paste this line here and change first to
second and this time my variable will be
B so my first input will be stored in
the variable a second input in the
variable B now one more thing we need to
consider so in Python every time the
user gives an input and the input
function returns the value it returns it
as a string so everything the user input
is basically a string but what we need
in our variables a and B are integer
values now this is very important
because we are going to perform
operations on these so we need to
convert the value returned by the input
function into int and this is how you do
it so you just say int and within
brackets you pass the input function so
now your string gets converted to and
int now if you want to convert these
string to float values it's exactly the
same thing just instead of int put their
float so now you have a and B both are
integer numbers now the third input that
you need from the user is what operation
the user wishes to perform on these
values so it can be addition subtraction
multiplication division of finding the
remainder so let's give this message to
the user so in here I say enter 1 for
addition and the /n is basically
skipping to a new line so on the second
line I'll have enter 2 subtraction enter
3 multiplication enter 4 division and
then enter 5 find the remainder so those
are the three inputs that we need from
the user our first number our second
number and the operation that needs to
be performed now once again this value
entered by the user the option again
will be converting this to an integer
now in this particular case it's
actually not necessary to convert the
option to an integer because you are not
going to perform any operations on it we
can simply do the comparisons
considering this to be a string
we'll still convert it to integer
because that is essentially what we mean
here I mean we are taking the input as
one of the numbers so why not have it
stored as a number and that would be
stored in my variable choice so now here
we'll introduce another new concept
which is the if-elsif ladder so what is
this ladder well so quite often in
programming we need to make comparisons
comparisons to take a particular path so
suppose I have a variable E and it
stores some value some integer value now
I'll see if E is less than 10 do this if
a is greater than 10 then there's a
whole different set of instructions that
you need to perform so to decide which
path to take that is when we use if or
else if so if I say if a greater than 10
perform this and if a is not greater
than 10 that is what comes in else so if
a is greater than 10 perform this else
that is if is not greater than 10 then
perform this separate set of functions
so I'll start typing this out we will
notice a syntax here and how exactly
this works and things will be much more
clear to you so I start my if statement
so I say if choice is equal to equal to
1 so if what integer the value stored
choice is equal to equal to 110 we'll
perform these statements under this
block now once again guys over here we
are using 2 equal to signs while here we
are using just a single equal to so the
single equal to sign indicates
assignment operator that is this value
here on the right-hand side of equal to
is assigned to the variable on the left
hand side but then again when you have 2
equal to signs that is a comparison
operator so it compares if the values on
its left and right are equal and it
returns a boolean result so it returns
either true or false now if this
expression here returns true then we
enter the if block and over here we'll
place the instructions to be executed if
this statement does result of truth so
if choice is equal to equal to 1 that
means the user wants to perform addition
so if the user wants to perform addition
I'll have a variable here say result and
salt will be equal to a plus P so this
is exactly how you do math or how you
perform this operation in any other
programming language you have a variable
to store the result in our case it's
even named result and the additions
perform by operator 1 plus operator 2 we
use a single equal to which is the
assignment operator so if choice is 1
then you perform the addition store the
value and result
now if choice is 2 so if choice
equal to equal to 2 then what do we do
now before I proceed with this I
purposely made a mistake here just so I
can explain this concept to you better
which is so when I put an if statement
here what happens is that the first if
statement condition is checked and then
irrespective of whether this is true or
false it will still check a second if
condition but it's not what you want
because see if choice is one obviously
choice cannot be equal to true or any
other number as such so here instead of
saying if we say L if so Elif is
basically a short for else if this is
true
so if choice equal to 1 do this else if
choice is equal to 2 do whatever we put
in this block so when we put elsif or
Elif instead of if what happens is that
if your first if condition results in
true it will skip all the other Elif
statements that you'll have along with
this if statement so again you can have
n number of Elif statements so let's
look into that first we'll put in our
result value for the choice equal to
equal to 2 so that means the user wants
us to stop tracked so you see result
equal to a minus B now guys if choice is
not one choice is not 2 then there's a
possibility choice would be 3 so again
we can have another LF here and this
time we check if choice is equal to
equal to 3 now if that is true we do a
into B because that's multiplication and
if that is also not true choice must be
equal to 4 in which case we do a by P
and if choice is not even equal to 4 it
might be equal to 5 in which case result
will be equal to a mod 5 so the mod of
basically returns the remainder of the
division so does a by B and whatever is
the remainder from this division it
returns that value and that will be
stored in result now see if choice is
neither one not two not three four or
five that means a user has entered some
number that was not a part of the option
now we do not know what this number is
but we know for sure that this value or
this choice is invalid so in that case
we see if none of these statements
resulted in true then we can have a else
statement where we say result is equal
to invalid choice so once again let's
recap till here we take two inputs from
the user we take a choice from the user
which could be any number between one
and five and we have the if Elif ladder
here to branch out based on the choice
the user has given so if it's choice one
you store the sum of a and B in result
joist to the difference of a and B
choice three the product choice for a by
B choice five the remainder of the
division and if it's none of these you
store invalid choice and result
so since Python supports dynamic
assignment we do not need to restrict
our variable value to be integer or
float it can be anything so far all
these values are integers or floats and
this particular value here is string and
it's completely fine this works well
with Python now out here what we do is
we'll just print out the result so
depending upon the choice the user has
given that particular value will be
stored in result and the result will be
printed out here and again if the user
give an invalid choice that's exactly
what will be printed out here now the
thing with else if ladder and why we did
not put if if if an instead we went with
an if else if ladder is because now if
this resulted in true the execution will
be interrupted here and we'll go to this
print statement
so it'll skip all these ellipse
statements because the system now knows
that the structure of this LF statement
is such that only one of them can result
in true the minute that one statement or
the one expression results in true it
skips outside of these statements so now
let's run this code so you give your in
my first numbers 20 and 10 then you have
a space here to give your option and
I'll choose multiplication and it gives
the results so 20 to 10 is 200 now you
can run this multiple times select the
different options to see how that works
and so that is a basic calculator
program so here we saw a better use case
of variables that is variables hold a
value and it can be used multiple times
so irrespective of what the value of a
and B is you do not need to change
anything else in the code because we are
not actually inputting numbers here but
the variable so the value of the
variable holds just changes but its use
does not change so that is the advantage
of using variables we also saw numbers
in Python we saw how you can input
numbers or you can accept numbers from
the user whatever the user enters is
string so basically how you can convert
that into another data type we also saw
something very important which is the
if-else statement or the if Elif ladder
why its use how it's used the advantages
how it runs and so on so that's quite a
lot of concepts covered in just one
program now let's move on to our third
program so the next thing we'll be
looking at our lists now list is
something new to Python and what are
they well basically they are a sequence
of objects so in Python everything is an
object a string is an object a class is
also an object numbers are objects and
so on so you can have multiple objects
stored one after another and that is
what lists - now unless the order of the
objects is very important now to say
that - must come after one but if you
are storing 2 after 1 then that is how
it will remain so the order in which you
form the list is exactly how it's stored
lists are also mutable as in you can
change the objects in a list you can
remove objects from a list you can add
other objects to the list even later on
after the list is created and elements
of a list can be accessed using indices
so let's begin first we look at how to
create a list so again a list will be
stored in a variable so my variable name
is LST here
and to create a list all you need are
these square brackets now within these
square brackets you put in all your
objects so as I mentioned earlier a list
does not pertain to a particular type of
object you can have strings numbers
floats everything stored together so
here our list would have 1 2 3 4 5 and
the strings simply learn stored so all
the elements of a list are separated by
commas and this is a very simple syntax
to create a list that's how it's done
now we print this list out and you can
see all the elements of the list here
are printed now as I mentioned earlier
to access individual element of a list
access the individual elements of a list
you will be using indices so how do
indices work in a list well every
sequence in Python as such has its index
starting with 0 so our number one here
is stored at index zero number two at
index 1 3 at 2 4 at 3 5 at 4 and the
word simply learn it's stored at the
index 5 so basically the length of your
string here is 6 but the last index of
your list would be 5 because the indices
start from 0 now if I want to access the
first element of the list I just say
list and within square brackets pass 0
which is our four subscript so you get 1
which is the first element of our list
now similarly if I want to access just
put in print statements here
well in ship with your notebook to print
out one line you actually don't need a
print statement but in this particular
cell will input multiple lines so I will
have a print statement now the next
thing I will be printing out is I want
to extract the number 4 here so how do I
do that well one is at 0 with index so 4
is add the third index so I just say
print LST and yeah
so we extracted for now suppose you want
to access a particular element but you
do not know the length of the string all
you know is that this element is the
last element of the string how do you
access the element then well this is
where negative indexing comes in handy
so with negative indexing the order of
the indices starts from the back and
this time we don't have
we start with one so simply learn is at
index minus 1/5 is at index minus 2 4 at
index minus 3 and so on so to extract
the last element add 3 minus 1 and you
get the string simply learn ok now I
want to find the length of the list to
find the length of the list or actually
any sequence in Python use the length
function and as a parameter to the
length function you pass the variable
which holds your list string or whatever
run this now the next thing we do is we
will find out the length of a string and
for the length of the string or any
sequence in Python you use the Len
function that's Elian and as a parameter
to this function you pass the variable
that holds your object or the sequence
and as you see here you get the length
so the length of the string is 6 you
have 6 elements in here now as I had
mentioned earlier lists are mutable so
they can be changed let's see how you
can mutate a list now there are
particularly functions in Bill functions
that are used with lists we look into
those now the first one is the append
function you see a pen function when you
want to add an element to the end of the
list so I want to add a number C 3 to
the end of this list
so I say LST dot append run this line of
code and now I'll print out LST as you
can see here 3 has been appended to the
end of the list now in the similar
manner you can also remove elements from
the list
LST dot remove is the inbuilt function
for doing so and as a parameter you pass
the element that you need to remove so
suppose I want to remove the string
simply learn so I just pass that in here
after which will print out our list and
as you can see here simply 11 has been
removed now you can use a function to
reverse this entire list so LST dot
reverse print out LST and as you can see
here your entire list has been reversed
now you can also sort the list out with
just one function which is of course
sort and shrimp out LST once again so
all your numbers have been sorted now 1
2 3 and since you had two threes it's
been brought to the middle so those are
some of the basic inbuilt functions that
you can use with lists
now here
introduce another topic which is the
for-loop so if you have gone through any
programming language before you know
there's this concept of loops which is
basically used to iterate or perform the
same task multiple number of times now
for loop is used for iterating over a
sequence mainly so here we say for I in
LST I'll explain the syntax to you so
LST is the sequence that we want to
iterate over and I is a variable which
takes every value in turn from the first
element of LST to the last element of
LST so for the first run of your for
loop I will take the value 1 for the
second run of your for loop I will take
the value 2 and this incrementation also
happens automatically when you're
dealing with for loop so here what I'll
do is I'll just print out the value of I
so you can see how it's proceeding so as
you can see here guys I has taken the
value of 1 followed by 2 3 3 4 & 5
exactly it's covered all the elements of
our list one by one so of course there
are multiple users of 4 but this is one
of the major advantages of using for
loop that's iterating over a sequence
this is true not only for lists but also
strings because strings are also
actually a sequence of characters we'll
see this in a while so that is the basic
of lists now another thing you can do
with list is you can have nested lists
so nested lists are basically lists
inside lists which is again possible
because as I told you list in Python are
not pertain to a particular datatype so
my second list would be called list 2
and the elements of this list and as
elements of this list will have 3 other
lists so my first element of this list
would be a list which contains the
integers 1 2 3 , and you give you a
second element of list 2 which is again
another list with integers 4 5 and 6 and
my third list would be the characters or
the strings ABC now let me print this
list out so as you can see here guys
list two is a list which is indicated by
these outer query places and with
than that we have three elements each of
the element is again a list now you must
be wondering like we iterated over our
list
LST using a for loop is the similar
thing possible
with a nested list well yes it is and
the key here is that for accessing every
element of a nested list you use a
nested for so basically you have a for
loop inside a for loop so you start with
for I in LST 2 now what this I will be
accessing is every element of LST 2 and
every element of LST 2 is actually a
list so I will hold each of these lists
the first time I will be holding the
list 1 2 3 the second time I will hold
the list which contains elements 4 5 6
and so on so once I has a list will now
iterate over the list that I holes
rather than LST - so you say for J in I
so now if I is holding the list which
has the elements 1 2 3 J will iterate
over this list and J will hold the
elements 1 2 3 consecutive ly so I'll
print out J and every time we are
printing out the elements of the inner
list I'll put in a print statement or to
skip to the next line and here in our
inner print statement say nth equal 2
coats so what this does is after
printing the statement it doesn't move
on to the next line it stays on the same
line so 1 2 3 should be printed on one
line and then before you print 4 5 6 it
skips to the next line so let's run this
code now so once you run the code you
see the results here 1 2 3 has been
printed in 1 9 4 5 6
next line and ABC on the third line so
that is how we deal with nested loops
and nested lists now the next thing we
look at are tuples
so tuples are just like lists except for
tuples are immutable so what I mean is
that like you can change lists even
after its created tuples are not so once
you create an they're static they cannot
be changed at all so other than that
pretty much everything similar and
center
twice there's a slight difference which
we look at now so let's start off by
creating a double name my double TPL
unlike before when we were creating
lists we had these square braces right
so this time for creating tuples we have
up caprices so that's the only
difference will be syntax and I'll put
in some elements into my topper now here
too we can have any data type so I can
even have a string in here then I'll
print out my double indexing for tuples
or extracting the various elements of
tuples just like as it works in lists so
you have TPL and she's given an index
here oh and you print out the object
stored at the 4th index now see with
lists you could manipulate them so
initially we had created a list LST
let's run that again these are the
elements in our list
LST now suppose I want to change this
particular 3 to 6 so that would be at my
index location 0 1 2 3 so I could say
LST 3 equal to 6 and then I'll print out
LST and as you see here you can change a
list or the elements of a list as simply
as that but now I want to do the same to
a tablet so is it possible might Apple
has these elements here 1 2 3 4 and
similar I want to change the number two
to number 10 so that is add the index
vacation one so I could say TPL 1 equal
to 10 following the same syntax run this
code and you see here an error has
occurred so this is what I mean by
tuples being immutable unlike lists
lists were prone to changes you can
change them whenever you like tuples you
cannot do that so the first time you
create a tuple and sure that it's
exactly what you want
now tuples are usually not used for this
very reason but it's good to know about
the various data types right in office
now Python supports another type of data
type which is strings strings are
basically a sequence of characters now
if you have gone through any of the
programming language before of course
you must be familiar with strings
because that's one commonly the type
used in almost all languages so let's
begin we'll start with storing us
string in available so my first variable
name is bad and in this variable I stole
my first ring now strings are always
within double quotes so I have my double
quotes here
and within that I put in the word let's
now I'll print out this variable but I
want to print out let's learn Python so
here what I'll show you is how you can
concatenate strings or concatenate a
string along with the string stored in
available so first you put in your
variable name pad and I want to
concatenate this to the string low and
fightin so your app inserted an extra
space which should appear after the word
less and now to concatenate them you
simply use the plus symbol and that's it
so that is your first string output now
we can also have this other string
that's learn Python stored in another
variable so I save at 2 which is my
second variable and within the coats
once again type in your string and then
we'll print this out that one plus VAT -
so now I see I have not inserted an
extra space here so that needs to be
done in this print statement so we see
valve on + and then in quotes we enter a
space and then again concatenate this
with vat - this is bad and not correct
that and now we can run our cell so yeah
as you see here let's lower I print it
out now you probably are aware of
substrate sub strings are a portion of a
string so how do we extract sub strings
from a string well again we use indices
to do so now if you want to extract just
a single character you can just put in
one single index such as 3 so bad of 3
they run this code and that is the
single code here now I want to extract
safe from let's just the word left how
is that done well once again we use
indices but now we need two indices that
is the start location and the end
location the start location is of course
0 curls are substring starts from the
very beginning of a string Val and D is
at these second index location so in
here I could put 2 but then again one
thing we must remember is
so when you're dealing with indices or
substrings the last element or the
character at the very last index that is
in this case at index two is excluded so
if you want the character a to to be
included then your index should be
incremented by one so in here I'll
insert three and that will display let
the substring be wanted now see when
you're starting from the beginning of a
string it's not complicity to mention
the zero if I remove the zero here just
leave the space empty Python
automatically assumes that you want
every character from the beginning of
the string bad if I run this code again
you'll get the same output the similar
manner suppose I born all the characters
from the third index up to the end of
the string in that case instead of
putting my last index here I can just
leave this part empty run the cell and
you'll get the last two indexes that's
basically your third and fourth index
elements now with strings you can also
find the length of a string just like we
did for lists using the length function
so you just say length of van and the
number of characters in the string is
displayed so what else can we do with
strings well we can use some other
function some other inbuilt functions
with strings here a few very common ones
one of them is index so I say product
index and then here I pass the element
whose index I want returned so I want
the index for the string et yep not just
a single character but two characters
and that starts at the index location
one now here are something pretty cool
with bytes and strings now suppose you
want to store a string in three separate
lines or any number of lines just more
than one how is this done well you'd
think that if I just put in double
quotes here and say hey put an enter
this should work let's see whether that
works so there's an end of line while
scanning the string literal so how do we
go about this is it not possible to
store a string in multiple lines well it
is but now we need to utilize something
other than just double quotes and single
quotes will have three codes so this
could be three single quotes or three
double quotes I'll show you how this is
done putting in three
both here and now that you've put in
three coats you can have your string in
multiple lengths so hey fightin is my
string okay in the first line fightin in
the second and then I close this up with
three coats again now let's try running
the cell so yeah that works that is how
you store a string in multiple lines now
when it comes to printing strings often
you require it to be printed in certain
format now as we saw previously here
when we have two variables each storing
a separate string and we are concatenate
in them we just use a plus sign to
concatenate them with other string
literals in between
now since this just utilizes two strings
and it's a pretty short print statement
looks fine
but what if you had like three four
variables which need to be put into the
string all together if we use the plus
sign again and again keep breaking a
sentence closing and opening string
literals putting in variables it'll look
kind of half sad so for this we have the
format function I'll show you how the
format function is utilized see I have a
variable name stores Sam and another
variable place which stores a string
Florida now I have a third variable pad
which should comprise of both e strings
other then some extra string literals so
basically it should be high followed by
Sam
so our traditional methods would say
this is how it's done hi close the
quotes put in name variable and then
plus quotes again open the codes again
and fill in the rest of your sentence
which is an exclamation mark so I want
it to say hi Sam exclamation welcome to
Florida which is stored in a variable
place so that is the traditional way we
would do it if I print this out just
have a space in here run it again
so yeah this works fine but as you see
this looks kind of messy we are closing
and opening these quotes again and again
so the simpler and the neater way of
doing this we use the format functions
you say bad equal to high and instead of
closing the quotes now just put in these
brackets here and then the
exclamation now these brackets up
basically placeholders so that where our
value for the variables will appear and
then we fill in the rest of the string
welcome to brackets again and that would
be the placeholder for our variable
place now once this skeleton of a string
is done we say dot format and now as pad
meters to the format function we will
pass the two variables which should be
taking the place of these brackets now
we'll do it in the same order of name
comma place so name will come here and
place will take up the spot
print pad out now and yeah so that's
done our string is printed now it's not
necessary that you need to have them in
these same order though what I mean is
it's not necessary that you need to put
your variables in the same order for
these format functions I could have
please first and then followed by name
now all you need to do is that this
bracket here should be the placeholder
for your second argument now the first
argument is considered at the 0th
position the second argument at the
first position so over here I'll just
put in one so that would be the
placeholder for name and over here
I'll have zero placeholder for available
place now run this code once again and
as you can see here the very same output
so now we have covered the very basics
of strings let's move on to our next
data type which is dictionaries so let's
begin with understanding what
dictionaries are well dictionaries are
sort of like lists as when you have
multiple objects stored in it but in
this particular case we have a pair or
we can say every object is a pair of a
key and a value so how exactly that
works well I'll write down the first
dictionary here and then we can better
understand what exactly this is so let
me create a dictionary of months so here
in the sticks 3-4 months we'll be
storing the keys as every month name and
the value for each of these keys will be
the number of days in that particular
month so my first month is January and
January has 31 days so this is how we
entered it guys the first value here is
the key and this is the value for this
particular key now this key can
an integer it can be a string or any
other data type and as of the value the
same case it can be any data type so now
I have January comma followed by your
second key which is February and then
the value for this key which is 28 since
February has 28 days in a non-leap here
but that's just how we'll consider it
followed by March April and so on so
I'll just paste the values in here so as
you can see you guys we have the month
names as the keys the number of days in
the month as the value for each key
right up till December so that is what a
dictionary is and in a dictionary well
these things are ordered as in later on
the order has not changed it's very
specific as to how you enter just like
lists and tuples now what could be the
requirement of doing this to better
understand dictionaries let's write a
program where we will be using this
dictionary we just created so we take an
input from the user which is basically
the number of days that has passed since
first jamberry so suppose the user
enters 45 what we need to output is
which is the 45th day of the year so the
45th day of the year is basically the
14th of February so that's how we gotta
go about this let's begin coding first
we'll take the input from the user and
I'm putting the int function first
itself because the input should be an
integer but we'll receive it as a string
enter the day of the earth now we'll
have a for loop to iterate through this
dictionary so guys I showed you before
how you can use a for loop to iterate
through a list it's a similar with every
sequence in Python a for loop yet it
[ __ ] through a list or tuple a string
and even dictionaries so for pi in
months so what we do here is we'll have
a variable see count and to this
variable count we'll keep adding the
number of days in the month that's fast
so if I say I actually it points to this
pair or de and if I say months of I this
will give me the value of that
particular key so count plus months of I
so I'll keep adding the number of days
in the month to count till count is
actually less than the input given by
the user if count plus months I is
greater than n which
given by the user in that case what we
do is we break out of this for loop and
if that is not the case then we will
continue adding monssai to account so
outside this for loop here we need to
initialize a count variable to zero so
let me explain this for loop once again
before we move ahead with this program
basically the user will enter a day of
the year that is the number of days
that's passed since first track now
based on that number what we need to
return the user is the particular day of
the month that this number corresponds
to so for that we take the input storage
and then we iterate over our dictionary
months now every time that we iterate
over this dictionary that is for every
iteration will first check if what count
holds so far plus the number of days in
the particular month that we are
iterating on currently is greater than n
so if this number is greater than n
means that we already surpassed the day
that we were supposed to output and in
that case we need to break out so if
count plus months of I is greater than n
that means that if we continue adding
months of I to count will be surpassing
the day that we need to output so we
will break out of the for loop and
outside the for loop will continue
processing this now as long as this is
not true we can continue adding the
number of days in that particular month
to count for example so the user enters
45 the first time count is 0 you come in
here and 0 plus months of I so I is or
the first iteration that is January so
you'll have count plus 31 that 0 plus 31
and we'll check if 31 is greater than n
which is 45 so of course 31 is not
greater than 45 so we come to the
statement here and so count will be
incremented to 31 now the for loop moves
on to the second iteration this time I
points to Feb ready so if you do 31 plus
28 that will be 59 59 is obviously
greater than 45 so we'll break out of
this for loop and what is next because
although we broke out of the for loop we
have not
yet reached 45 so out here we will print
out the day will see it D and I'll be
using the format function here so I have
a placeholder which will display the
value as to which day of the year it is
it is the the date off followed by the
month now out here dot format now it's
pretty obvious that this placeholder
will be taken by the month which will be
I but what about this placeholder which
should hold the date well to find that
out we just need to do n minus count so
n is the total number of days that we
have to go through and count as a number
of days that we actually went through
and broke out of the for loop
sothey so the difference between these
two values will give you the date for
that particular month now
another problem that we will be facing
here is using the variable I since I was
created only the for loop it scoped
ended with D for loop so to keep the I
variable alive let's give this a global
axis so I'll declare I outside the for
loop and now you can use I in here so
let's run this program enter the day of
the year
well months is not defined we did not
run this function here so with
dictionaries or anything in Python
actually the syntax is pretty important
made a few syntax mistakes here quickly
correct that let's run our code once
again so our months dictionary is
created now we can run up to bra which
utilizes the months dictionary and it's
working fine it says it's the 40th of
February which is right so I hope you
understood dictionaries and how it can
be utilized so before we move ahead we
look at a few functions that's used with
numbers now a lot of these functions are
provided under the math library so this
is the first library that we will be
exploring in Python today and it's
actually a pretty straightforward
library and we will just look at some of
the functions that's most commonly used
in here because it has a large number of
functions and it's not possible for us
to go through everything now along with
that we'll also look at a few functions
which is not specifically in the math
library but then they are build
functions used with numbers so let's
start now my first variable will store
and integer 5 and I want to print out a
square of this number so within codes I
have the string e to the power 2 and out
here so previously we saw that we can
just use double a strict symbol to show
power but we have a function which does
this much more neatly which is P o W
sort for power now to this function you
just pass your variable which stores the
integer and the power to which you want
to trace so this way you can do it to
the power 2 3 5 10 anything so I'll run
this code missed out a comma there and
as you see here e to the power 2 is 25
which is returned by our function POW
now let's put our maths library so this
is how you import libraries in Python
just use the import keyword followed by
the name of the library now my first
function from the math library would be
to find the square root of a number so
have square root here say math dot s qrt
passed the variable which stores the
integer to this and there you go that's
the root of 5 you also have the seal
function which basically returns the
smallest integer that's greater than or
equal to the number that you pass to
this function which is copy/paste the
statement in here
sealing and the functions called C as in
c e i l did this since a was an integer
math rot seal will not really make sense
with this particular variable so I'll
just put in some value six point seven
eight now let's run this code and it
returns seven that's curse seven is the
closest or the smallest integer that is
greater than or equal to six point seven
eight similar manner you could also use
the flow function which again comes with
this math library or the math module and
that will give you six so the matter
flow function returns a smallest teacher
that is less than or equal to the flute
or the number that's passed to this
function now like you have the modulus
operator the math module also has a
function
does the exact same thing and that's
called F mode to this you pass two
numbers the divisor and the dividend
this is six-five the should return the
remainder of the division so basically
six is divided by 5 and the remainder of
this is what F mod returns which is 1 so
6 by 5 returns 1 so you can explore more
functions within the math module these
are just sub common ones and we quickly
had a look at them we will now move on
to the next topic
so while learning list we looked into
what for loops are and how they work how
you can use them to iterate over the
sequence now there's another form of
loops which is the while loop now while
for loop is mainly used iterate over a
sequence while loop is used to perform a
block of operations repeatedly an
unknown number of times so here we learn
while loop and I'll show you the syntax
and we learn while loop through a
program so you better understand its
utility so we write a program to find
out if a number entered by the user is
an amstrong number or not so first of
all for all those who don't know what an
amstrong number is the and strong number
is any number that is equal to the sum
of its digits raised to the power of the
number of digits in the number so I will
show you an example if you say the
number 10 to find if 10 is an am strong
number you got to basically do 1 that is
the first digit of the number 10 raised
to the number of digits in 10 so that's
2 plus the second digit in number 10
raised to the number of digits in 10
which is 2 so now this is equal to 1
which is not equal to 10 therefore 10 is
not an Armstrong number now if I take
the number 153 to find if this is equal
to an Armstrong number you say 1 to the
power of 3 plus 5 to the power of 3 plus
3 to the power of 3 and now these digits
actually do add up to 153 which
classifies 153 as an Armstrong number so
now that you know what an Armstrong
number is we can begin typing in the
code for it the first thing we have to
do
is we'll take the input from the user
and store it in a variable N and this
input needs to be converted to integer
now we have to raise every digit to a
power equal to the length of the number
therefore we need to find the length of
the number now let's do that
so I'll store the length of the number
in L now of course there's a way of
finding the length for an integer
through a loop but it's much simpler if
we convert this number back to a string
and then use the Len function on the
string to find its length so use the Len
function on the string form of n so
basically what we're doing here I'll
explain it once again n is an integer we
are converting that to a string and then
we are using the Len function on it
because you cannot directly use the Len
function on a number so now L stores the
number of digits in our integer n okay
so before we move ahead let's figure out
our logic so basically we have to
extract each digit from a number in and
this can be easily done through the mod
operator so if I do n mod 10 the last
digit of n is extracted now if I want to
extract the second last digit of n I can
just divide n by 10 so suppose n was a
three-digit number once you divide it by
10 it becomes the two-digit number so
now you have the first two digits of
your number in n again if you do the
modulus operator on this that is you do
mod tin you can extract the second digit
of it
so using this logic we can extract each
digit of N and acid when we do this we
will simultaneously Zee's the digit to
the power of L which is the length of a
number and then we will keep adding this
number that we received to another
variable say sum and at the end of a
while loop that is once all these digits
have been extracted and raised to the
power of L and added to some we will
compare if sum is equal to n and if this
is so then of course our number is an
amstrong number so let's begin now as I
mentioned previously since we are going
to be modifying n it's better that we
store it in another variable before
proceeding with our Lu
so I'm creating this other variable num
here which will hold the value of n now
here's my while loop and this is how you
write it so you have the keyword while
space followed by the condition to be
met now I want to run this while loop
till num actually exists what I mean is
once you have extract the last digit of
num num is empty then you can exit out
of the while loop until then we'll
continue repeating the instructions
within this block now the first thing
you do is you extract the last digit
from num so I'll store this in the
variable R M as in remainder so you say
num mod 10 and we get the last digit of
num now we will reduce num to two digits
so that the next time we do num more 10
be able to extract the second last digit
of now so num equal to num by 10 now
guys here we would be using double slash
preferably because single slash returns
a float value double slash always
returns a whole value an integer which
is exactly what we want and now we will
have a variable sum let me just quickly
declare this outside a loop now some
will be equal to some plus the remainder
raced to the power of n so as you guys
saw previously we can use the power
function for this now these three
statements must be repeated in the while
loop until num holds nothing anymore and
once that's done outside here we'll have
an if statement where we'll check if sum
is equal to equal to n which is the
number entered by the user if that is so
we'll print out this is an Armstrong
number else print out this is not an
Armstrong number I'm strong with the
capital e and yup
so that's our code let's run this code
enter a number I'll be entering 10 first
Alexei is 10 is not an Armstrong number
enter 1 53 which is actually an
Armstrong number so let's see if that's
what our program says well yeah it does
rightly say that 153 is an Armstrong
number so programs working fine
I hope you understood how the while loop
is used now let's move on to our next
topic which is functions so what are
functions well functions are these
blocks of code which can be called from
anywhere in your program so why do these
blocks of code exist why can we just
write an entire code in a complete flow
see often when you write a program there
are a number of operations being
performed now if you put in every
operation one after the other a program
looks kind of clustered it won't make
much sense and it won't be organized
well this is one of the reasons why we
use functions with functions you can
actually separate out the different
operations that are to be performed for
example if you are writing a program
which will be performing addition
subtraction multiplication division all
of these you can have a separate
function for doing each of these
operations so that way the minute a
person looks at your program they are
able to understand better what is
happening and it's not just lines of
code that are just everywhere now the
other advantage of using functions is as
I mentioned before they can be called
from anywhere in the program and this
makes them reusable so if you have a set
of instructions which are to be repeated
sometime in the beginning of a program
sometime in the middle of the program
and then again in the end of the program
instead of having to write this code
again and again what we can do is we can
just have a function which holds all
these lines of instruction and whenever
necessary wherever necessary you just
make a call to this function so now that
we understood kind of what functions are
let's write a very simple program to
demonstrate how functions work and
basically their syntax well here I am
going to write a program where we'll be
adding and subtracting some numbers
taken from the user so here I'll be
writing a program where functions will
be declared just for addition and
subtraction so let's begin writing a
function now for defining a function you
start with the keyword def a space
followed by the function name so every
function has a unique function name now
there are cases where functions have the
same function name but that is slightly
an advanced topic which field
or look into right now so now we ensure
that all our functions have a unique
functioning so my first function which
is the function that we'll be taking in
few numbers and finding the difference
between them will be called subtract and
now functions are always followed by
these curly brackets it is not
compulsory to put anything within the
curly brackets but in this particular
case we will be putting something inside
okay so before I proceed let me give you
a few terminologies now whatever you put
inside these brackets they are called
parameters or arguments to the function
so a function which does not accept any
parameters are called non parameterize
functions and functions that do except
parameters are called parameterize
functions so for now this is a non
parametric function now function name
just like any other block in Python is
followed by the colon and the very next
line with your indentation you enter
your code that is the operation that
this function is meant to perform so
this function will be finding the
difference between the two numbers let's
say 20 and 10 so the difference between
20 and 10 will be stored in diff and
then what you got to do is you need to
return this value but where are we
returning this variable to well that is
the next part of a code whenever you
define a function it's of no use
whatsoever unless you make a call to
this function so a call to this function
is basically like your program saying
hey I need to use this function right
now so whatever's in your body perform
that operation and give me back some
value of curs once again this return
statement is completely optional in
functions you can just print out the
value that's stored in your variable def
right here but just to show you how this
works we'll be returning this value and
technically you should always be
returning values from a function rather
than printing it out unless the very
purpose of the function is to print out
something so now let's make a call to
the function enter the function name of
course
followed by the brackets always have
brackets for your functions and that is
it that makes a call to your function
but see here we are actually returning a
value from this function so where does
this value get stored well the value is
returned back to the call statement so
while you're making your call you also
need a variable here which will store
the returned value from the function
that you're calling so result here will
store the value diff once it's returned
so that is how this works if I run this
code now now what I need to do is
obviously once I have the result
I should print it out now let's run this
code and as you can see here its result
holds the value 10 which has been
returned so let me explain the flow of
this program once again now always the
statements that are executed are now the
functions for the statements just below
or above the functions so the functions
are your second priority any other
statement is always executed before it
and the function will only be executed
when a call is made to the function so
your execution starts here in this
particular case which is a call to this
function subtract so then the control
passes to subtract performs this
operation and returns this value diff
now this values always return to the
very same line that the call for the
function is made from which is this line
line number five and we have this
variable result here which is all ready
to hold this value or store the value
returned by the function that is diff so
now result holds a value 10 and then we
print it out now the next step is we'll
convert this function to a parametrized
function so what I'll do here is we'll
have the values 10 and 20 inserted in
these brackets so that means we are
passing these values to this function
and if values are being passed to a
function the function should also be
able to capture those values so over
here we'll have two variables because we
have two values passed to it a and B so
that a will store the value 10 and B
will store the value 20 now B holds a
value 20 which is
create a number so we see a B minus a
and then we returned F here again DIF
will be captured and result and the rest
of the process exactly the same so let's
run a code again so the results the same
but as you can see here we slightly
modified our function so that is
parametrized and non parametrized now
there are situations where you actually
aren't sure about the number of
parameters that will be passed to your
function so this could vary from
execution to execution can this also be
handled in Python yes definitely this
can also be handled Python and that is
what we look at next
so our next function that we'll be
adding to this very program is a
function to find the sum of numbers so I
have a function here def find some and
in here we need to find out a way to
somehow allow this function to accept
any number or very number of arguments
so for doing this we have a keyword
which is arcs and args is always
followed by a single asterisk so
basically this is like saying it's a
list and any number of arguments that
you pass it's stored in the list format
in arcs and then you can extract them
one by one from you using a for loop so
now that you have arcs here what we can
do is have a for loop for I in arcs and
you have a variable sum or since sum is
a keyword
I'll say add equal to add plus I and
then out here I can return add and of
course before entering the for loop I
also need to once define add assign it
to zero so what's happening here is guys
no matter how many arguments you pass
here arcs is like this list which holds
the arguments using the for loop I will
iterate over every element stored in
arcs and it will be added to this
variable add and then finally we'll be
returning add now we can make a call to
this again since this function returns a
value we need to have a variable here
which is ready to accept the value
they'll be result to then i say find
some say find some and pass numbers to
it so i'll be passing 10 and 20 here
and then printout result to now in the
very next line I have another result
make a call to the same function this
time passing three arguments so let's
see this works and as you can see your
guys it did work our function find some
is able to accept any number of
arguments now this one more key word
which is squawks okay so we'll be
modifying our function find some now
what is quacks see often you're just
passing any number of arguments but
sometimes you need to pass these
arguments along with some labels or C
keys so you're saying a is equal to 10 B
is equal to 20 C is equal to 30 now I
want my function to capture these values
as it is the first parameter 10 should
be stored in a 20 in B 30 in C and so on
so here we're associating values with
some keys so in that case we will be
using this quacks keyword here and how
this changes our code is now it's not
just 10 and 20 but we can say a equal to
10 B equal to 20 so you see this kind of
a pairs can be passed over here too we
can have equal to 10 B equal to 20 C
equal to 30 so now here we will be
changing this asked to quarks because
that's what we'll be accessing and when
we say dot items so you gotta say quark
store items to receive each pair of
values that's like a comic 10 V comma 20
so basically quarks rot items returns at
Apple now you want the second element of
the tupple because as I mentioned
previously the tupple contains a comma
10 so 10 which is the second element is
what you want so in here when I points
to topple you'll extract the second
element of that topple which is at index
location 1 obviously and add it to this
variable ad now let's run this code here
and as you can see your guys it's worked
out just right so the difference is 10
and then our second call to find some
returns 30 a third call returns 60 now
the next thing we look at is nested
functions so just like nested loops
nested function
our functions with them functions so
let's begin
create a function func one here and in
here and have a print statement just
prints out this is the first function
now inside this function I'll create my
second function which will be called
nested from and the nested funk will
print out this is the nested function
now what we'll do is we'll create
another function out here so these two
functions in here that forms the nested
function we'll create a third function
and out a function which I'll name out
of funk and this will print out this is
the outer function so now if we make a
call to func one that will not really
execute the nested function because only
the definition of this function is
nested there's no call to the nested
function specifically so what we can do
here is we'll add a return statement and
the return statement will basically make
a call to the nested function and then
return the control to the calling
statement for func one so func one call
statement is here now see although we
have the return statement here I'm not
having a variable here because this
return statement does not really return
back a value it just makes a call to
this nested function and the nested
function two has nothing to return back
just prints out a statement so now let
me run this code and as you can see here
guys once you made a call to func one
the statement within func one was
executed which is this is the first
function and then this part was skipped
we went to the next statement within
func one which is the return statement
that makes a call to the nested function
so this not only makes a return call but
it also makes a call to the nested
function the nested function gets
executed which prints out the statement
here and then the control is transferred
back to the line that makes your main
call so that is how nested functions
work now you must be wondering why I
created this outer function here as re Y
so with Python functions are also
objects so basically you can pass a
function like you
pass an object or function so here to
[ __ ] one I'll pass out a funk as an
object and here I'll be accepting this
function which is passed as an object
and then within the nested function I'll
use this parameter which is passed to
func one to make a call to this outer
function so if I say called
funk which is basically the function
name and then just add the parentheses
to it it'll make an automatic call to
this function here okay so now let's run
the code well I just deleted this
bracket by mistake put that back in
there close the quotes run a code once
again and yeah so all our three
functions have been executed so I'll
once again
explain what we did here I made a call
to func one passing this function as an
object to it now this function accepted
this object in this variable called func
and it first printed out the statement
in func one came here to the return
statement which made a call to the
nested function the nested function
printed out this is the nested function
and then it made a call to outer
function and then outer function printed
out this is the outer function so this
kind of passing of functions as objects
is also possible and that was a
modification with functions we saw which
may not come in very handy especially as
a beginner but it's good to know this is
a capability that Python provides now
the next thing we look into after
functions is of course classes so as you
probably already know python is an
object-oriented programming language
what this means that all the functions
and data are actually tied up around an
object so using functions and the data
you are describing an object so that
really becomes a link between a
programming paradigm and the real world
situations for example over here we will
be creating a class called person so
when I do this what I'm saying is that
I'm going to define a person here or I'm
going to create a blueprint of a person
here providing the basic functionalities
of a person and providing some data
which is always associated with a person
now the action
data will obviously vary from person to
person but what the art essentially will
be the same for example a person will
have a name
every person has a name now the value of
the name or what the name actually is
that could vary from person to person
but again it is essential that a person
will have any so let's start coding here
and through the code I will explain to
you how classes work now classes tie up
everything that is they tie up the
functions and the attributes of an
object so class person so that is
exactly what a class person does now in
here first we'll start defining the
functions now what are the functions of
a person or what are the methods or
operations of a person well a person can
talk so we create a function here called
talk so def talk and in our function
we'll just print out hi I am say Sam now
our second function will be vote occurs
again people vote so in here
now a second function would be vote
because people can vote now minorities
cannot vote so we'll have an if
statement in here which will check if H
is greater than or equal to 18 the
person can vote so we'll print out I am
eligible to vote else I am not eligible
to vote now you must be wondering what
this ages well age is an attribute which
I will explain to you later for now I
just put in the value age here and it's
still actually not complete we'll
complete it in a while so those are our
two functions or are two methods
associated with a person now see we want
to be more specific we cannot say that
these two functions are just absolutely
general because every person is not Sam
every person is not eligible to vote or
every person is not not eligible to vote
so here what we'll do next is we'll
create an object so when we create an
object we are basically creating an
entity of a person so our first object
could actually represent Sam and whether
Sam is eligible to vote or not that is
Sam's age another object that we create
could represents a
for example someone named Richard
so our second object that we create
could represent another entity say a
person named Tina so that is how objects
work and that's the very purpose of
objects in a class so let's begin
creating our object so you say obj one
our first object and an object is of the
class type so we say person and now
within person we need to pass the values
for this object so if object is
representing a person we need to pass
the name of the person the age of the
person and in this particular case in
fact I am even passed the gender of the
person so my first person's name would
be Sam gender is male and age is 22 now
does putting the values like this mean
anything well of course not because we
have not created any attributes yet so
what are attributes well I'll explain
that to you through another concept
which is called constructors
so constructors also functions they are
a special type of function and Pythian
they are called init method and this is
how you do it you have double
underscores and then you write in it and
then double underscore again so it's a
method and now init method in this
particular case will be parametric so
guys basically this line here is a call
to this init method of constructor so
here we need to access the values which
are passed to this now the first value
which is passed to it is name the second
value is gender and the third value is
age now as we are going through the init
method and better understanding objects
let's understand another keyword self so
what is self self basically is a
reference to the object that is making a
call to a function so if you have
program before like in Java or something
self is like this the keyword this which
is a pointer to an object self is the
same but in Python you always pass self
when you're dealing with objects so here
you mentioned self within the
constructor and the reason self is not
passed to the constructor is because
it's actually passed but not
exclusively so this object when you are
making a call to the constructor the
object that you're creating using that
call that is what self refers to so here
self refers to obj now down here we will
assign values to our attribute now these
are actually just values that we are
accepting from here they are not are of
facial attributes in this particular
case my official attributes have the
same name because that would make things
simpler and when a name would still be
called name so you say self dot name and
assign the value name that you received
from the call to the constructor here
followed by self dot gender equal to
gender self dot H equal to H so let me
explain what's happening here once again
we have class person which is basically
the blueprint of a person
now this blueprint is not specific to a
person it's just in general so the
functions that we define here could
apply to any person but then the
attributes will be specific to a person
the attributes being named gender age
all people don't have the same name
gender and age so for that purpose will
be creating objects which are called
instances of a class and each object is
associated with its own values for the
attributes and to assign those values
that is why we have the in it or the
constructor here so we'll make a call to
this constructor so to make a call to a
constructor you are not actually putting
the constructor name we are just making
a call to the class so that is the
syntax not just in Python but any
programming language which is object
oriented and in the call we pass the
values for the attributes over here
referring to the object that is making
this call which is self we'll assign
these values to attributes so these
three attributes gender name gender and
H are common with all the objects that
we create but the value of these
attributes will change from time to time
so here we just created our first object
which is obj one now my second object
obj2
we'll be a woman so her name will be
Tina gender female and H is 16 so now we
have both our objects here what we do
next is once a objects are created the
attributes have values assigned to them
we can call the functions okay so for
that before we do that actually come
back to your function deff top now here
we initially just said print hi I am Sam
but see the first person's name is Sam
the second person's name is not Sam
it's Deena so we need to be able to
change this so what we do here is we'll
make this kind of dynamic where will not
be entering the name in the code we'll
just give in the variable name so I'll
see self dot name so hi I am and the
name that follows will be the name
attribute associated with the object
that makes a call to this function talk
so now you're like an object makes a
call to this function well yes when we
are dealing with classes and we have the
functions and the attributes associated
or tied up around an object we need to
be specific about which object is making
a call to the function so for that if I
see obj one dot talk then we are
basically making a call to this function
talk using the object obj1 and so in the
parameters here will accept self and
self will be pointing to the object
that's making the call which is obj one
so over here when I say self dot name it
prints out the name of obj one which is
Sam and similarly if I make a call to
talk using obj to the self will then
refer to object to and self dot name
would print out Tina now in the same way
would also we'll be accepting an object
and we'll make a call to vote using an
object so obj 1 dot would obj 2 dot
would okay so I hope that was clear now
we can run a program okay so what went
wrong here guys there's an error if you
check out the error it says name H is
not defined but we did have the
attribute age defined here see if you
come back to your vote function you'll
notice we missed out self when you
seeing just an attribute age it has no
meaning the age attribute does not exist
without an object so here once again we
need to say self dot H and let's run a
code now so we have a output here the
first time we made a call with obj one
to the talk function and it printed out
hi I'm Sam we then made a call to the
vote function which said I'm eligible to
vote Chris as you can see here Sam is 22
years old then we made a call to talk
using Ruby g2 and it said hi I am Tina
and we've then made a call to vote using
obj to Richard I'm not eligible to vote
Kristina is under 18 so with that we
have covered all the very basic topics
of Python next what we'll be moving into
are the libraries which are used with
Python of course if you know anything
about python there are a large number of
libraries use with python but today here
we just constitute on the few of the
most important and popular ones so first
one's gonna be the numpy package
so the numpy package is basically an
array processing package it provides you
the facility or the capability to build
n dimensional arrays so the n can be any
number basically you can have a single
dimensional two dimensions even ten
dimensions although that's never used
but yes it provides you the capability
of doing that along with which it
provides you a few functions and makes
it easier to deal with these arrays so
let's begin we'd be looking at the very
basics of numpy today so the first thing
you need to do is you have to import
numpy if you say import numpy and so
that we don't actually have to type the
entire word numpy every time we are
using a function from the numpy package
we will shorten this or use it as NP so
let's start off with creating an array
or numpy array my array name would be PR
l1 and to create an array you say MP dot
array and now to this we will pass the
elements of the array in the form of
lists so you have your bracket inside
which you will pass the elements of the
array and that
we'll be in the form of a list so you
always have these square brackets guys
do not forget these square brackets they
are very important to the syntax of
creating an umpiring now within this we
can start inserting our elements okay so
let's begin with creating a single
dimensional array in Nampa so just put
on your elements one two three four five
separated by commas just as you would
for a list and that would be your first
numpy array now we will print this out
run our code and here you go so that is
your first array now let's look at how
you can create a two dimensional array
so again the elements passed to the
function array would be a list so if you
want to create a two-dimensional array
basically you're going to create a list
of lists so my first element of this
array would basically be the first row
of my array that would be one two three
and then comma and then input the second
row of your array that's four five six
this would be added to let's run this
code now so that's our two dimensional
array guys we have the elements one two
three in the first row four five six in
the second row now arrays can be formed
directly from lists that is you can
actually create a list which contains
these elements and then just add the
name of the lists to the function array
for that let's see how it's done
creating my first list l1 which will
hold the elements a B and C and then my
second list l2 will hold the elements D
E and F so now we have both our lists
let's use these lists to create a third
numpy array we say NP dot array just as
before and this time your elements
actually passed the array function are
l1 comma l2 so as you can see here this
formatting is much neater but obviously
it does not make sense to often do this
because you're utilizing like double the
amount of space you're actually creating
two lists first and then putting these
lists in whereas these lists will never
come in handy again so I'm just showing
you for the purpose of knowing that the
scan
didn't not probably the ideal method of
doing it though let's print out our
three so yeah
that's our three so now that we saw how
you can create arrays in Nampa let's
look at how you can access these IDs so
again with arrays - just like any other
sequencing we will be using indexing so
just like we saw with lists and all the
other sequences iodized also have
indices and that's exactly what we'll be
using to access the elements of an array
okay so let's go back to the second
array which created which is array -
I'll just print that out here okay so
those are the elements of array - now I
want to extract the elements of the
first row of my added skipping every
alternate element so let's see how that
is done
first of all enter your array name and
within square braces the indices go in
now how do these indexes go in okay so
the first thing you have to mention is
the rules so for that I say 0 colon 1
that means that all the rows from 0 to 1
excluding 1 will be printed out or will
be extracted from array 2 now obviously
0 to 1 excluding 1 is just 0 suppose our
array had 5 rows and we want to extract
4 of them then we would say 0 to 5 so
that would be extracting all the rows
from the 0th row up till the 4th row
because always the last index is
excluded now that is just the row spot
so in this particular case we want to
extract only our first true so we say 0
to 1 now the second part is where we
need to specify our columns so again the
format for specifying the columns is
just like that for rows if suppose our
array had 5 columns and we want to
extract the columns 3 & 4 we would say 3
to 5 so since 5 would be excluded column
number 3 would be taken column number 4
would be taken but in our particular
case we want to extract all the columns
so we just say 0 - although 2 does not
exist
means that we'll take all the columns
from zero to one that'll be our two
columns okay and then following this
here's something new so in fact just
like list it's not that new once you put
your colons here you can specify a
number which will dictate a pattern of
skipping elements so what I mean is if
you want to skip every second element
you can just say 2 here if you want to
skip every third element say 3 and when
I'm sink skipping elements I mean column
wise not row wise so if I say skip every
second element it would print out 1 and
then 3 then that's the first row now in
the second row it would print out 4 & 6
so you see the second elements which are
2 & 5 are skipped now even to print it
in reverse you can just say minus 1 so
then you would have the elements printed
as 3 2 1 6 5 4 okay so that is how the
indexing for arrays were now once again
just like in lists if you are taking all
the rows or columns right from the
beginning you do not have to put 0 you
can just skip that part it's
automatically assumed to be so and once
again if you're taking all the rows or
columns right till the end you can also
skip the nth index now here we'll still
keep one cuz the only one the first show
to appear so if we do delete one here
that means the first and the second row
will appear and we want to skip every
second element so enter two here run
this and yes so we received 1 & 3 so
basically how this works I will explain
it once again you're seeing you want all
the rows from 0 it to first
so zeroth row is extracted but because
the end index is always ignore the first
row is not extracted and similar manner
when you go to your colon section you
seen you want to extract all your
columns so that's 0 it column up till
the 2nd column or the first to the third
column so since you're extracting all
your columns from the first row you'll
be extracting the numbers 1 2 3 now
again in this you're seeing you want to
skip every second number and finally on
your extracting is 1 & 3
now here's another great advantage with
by a DS one of the main reasons actually
that we use numpy a DS is not only does
it let us create very powerful arrays it
also provides us as functionalities
which makes dealing with these arrays
very simple for example if you would
have created a normal array and you
wanted to increment every element of the
array by one you would actually have to
create a for loop it trade through every
element of the array and manually add
one to it but in the case of numpy
arrays it's much more simple so if I'm
going to add one to every element of my
array arr2
I can simply do we are r2 plus one and
yeah as you see every element has been
incremented to one very simple isn't it
similarly you can perform other
operations on it too for example I'll be
multiplying every element in my array
two with the number two and yup that's
your result and again you can also
easily find the transpose of the array
by just invoking it with capital T here
let's run this so that's the transpose
of your re2 now there are a lot more
functions which you can definitely
explore it's out there on the internet a
lot more you can do with nappa arrays
for now we are just covering the basics
of it and now we will be moving on to
our next package in Python which is
pandas so pandas are one of the most
popular packages used for data analysis
it provides you a way to store your data
in a structured format now pandas
provide to such structured format
the first one is series which allows you
to store data in a one-dimensional form
and then you have data frames which is
sort of like tables now the thing with
pandas is it does not just allow you to
store this data but again like numpy it
gives you a lot of functions to work
around with this data and analyze this
data now in fact pandas also provides
you methods to plot graphs using these
data's that you have stored in your data
frame or series so we'll be looking
again at the very basics of pandas today
just like any other package before you
start using it you need to import pandas
and we will be importing this
speedy now as I mentioned before it has
two forms of structure data
the first one is series which is what
we'll be looking at right now so series
are one-dimensional data storage let's
say I have a variable data and to create
a series we will first create a list say
1 2 3 4 and then we will use the series
function from pandas that speedy dot
series and 2 this will pass
our list this function will basically
return back your series which will then
store in series 1 our variable now let's
print this out
I did not run my first line here which
is importing pandas so that is a series
as you can see here guys all our
elements are lined up one below the
other
on the right side and these numbers that
you see on the left side are basically
the indices so by default the indices
are integers from 0 up till the number
of elements present minus 1 and the type
of the value stored in our series is in
64 now again of course we are completely
allowed to change this indices value so
let's see how that's done
create a list again named indexed which
I'll add these characters a B C D and E
I'll have my second series 2 which will
be equal to PD dot series and to this I
can pass first the elements that I
require in my array since I have just
four elements I just need four indices
now to my series function first I will
pass the list of the elements followed
by the list of the indices and that is
how you can assign your very own indices
run the cell and here you go so now the
indices have changed to whatever you
specified now another way of specifying
the indices is through passing a
dictionary to your function series so
let's look at how that's done have my
thought series here series 3 VV dot
series and now since I'm passing
dictionaries have curly braces and now
we can pass our index
and the value associated with the index
second index value associated with this
and so on it's not one this would be
three and that's it so that's our series
three it's essentially the same series
as before just done in a different way
so there you go that's creating a series
using a dictionary so we just looked at
three ways you can create series now of
course there are other ways like you can
also pass an array to a series let's
move on to data frames next so unlike
series data frames actually provides you
a table like format so here you even
have column names so how is data
well first once again we'll bring in by
creating a list in fact I'll have two
columns in this particular data frame
and we'll have a list of values for each
of these columns now to create my data
frame first I can just create a
dictionary so I'll say first which will
be the name of my first column and the
values they'll come under this first
column would be list 1 similarly I'll
give the name for my second column and
then the values that fall under the
second column which is list 2 now I can
finally put this all together to form my
data frame so you say PD dot data frame
that's the function for creating the
data frame and I'll just pass my
dictionary data to this store this in my
variable DF and let's run the cell okay
so looks like our data frame is created
let's now print this out and that is
what a data frame looks like guys so you
have your indices here once again and
you have columns and rows so it's
basically our table like format now data
frames comes very handy in fact it's one
of the most you structures when you are
actually using Python for a project
because the kind of data we receive
these days it's huge amount of data and
it's always in the table like format so
this is how you can actually view it and
you can perform operations or analyze
the data with much ease using the
functions provided by pandas and other
libraries so that is it for pandas let's
move on to our third library which will
be matplotlib so the Mac lot
the package in Python is used mainly for
plotting troughs and with just two or
three lines of code you have a neat
graph plotted so here today will be just
exploring some of the very basic graphs
which are often used so let's begin once
again we need to import my plot lip and
from Matt plot lip will be importing
this library pie plot as p LT pi plot is
basically the one that is specific to
plotting the graphs that will be
plotting today now for plotting the
graph first of all you need some data so
first I will be creating two lists list
X which has one 10 12 24 and 30 just a
few random numbers there and another
list Y because you know for plotting
most graphs you need at least two values
so 10 20 30 40 and 50 ok great so now
that we have our data we can begin
plotting now the first plot I'll be
showing you is the most basic of them
all you just say PLT dot plot x comma y
so the list x takes up the x-axis and
the list Y takes up the y-axis now in
the jupiter notebook actually if you
just run this code this will display
your graph but if you are using any
other IDE you need to go ahead with one
more line of code which is PLT dot show
let's run the code now and there you go
so you see how just two lines of coding
gave you this nice neat graph here so
all your values in your list x basically
takes up the x-axis and all your values
list Y takes up the y-axis now we will
look at a few more other graphs which
are commonly used the second one we'll
be looking at is the bar graph so you
just say PLT bar again pass x and y and
PLT dot show and that's a bar graph mat
plot Lib also provides for a histogram
so I'll show you that too here you just
use the hist function and of course
histogram guys it does not require two
values it basically matches up all your
elements in one list or one data frame
so it basically
finding out the distribution of the
values within a single list or a single
object you just pass cy and PLT dot show
and that's your histogram so just
histogram does not really make sense
in this particular case because it just
shows that these are the values that are
present in our y-axis as you can see 10
is present 20 30 40 50 if we had two
fifties then things would be slightly
different let's modify our list here
once let's just copy this why well let's
just create another list here just y1
put in values 10 20 30 40 50 50 and then
plot a histogram using y1 so there you
go so basically histogram just gives you
a measure of the elements which are
present or the measure of the quantity
of the elements which are present in
your list or your data frame or whatever
object you're passing and finally we
looked at the scatter plot again just
say PLT dot scatter pass x and y PLT dot
show and that just charted craft
so this basically marks the elements or
you could say basically relates the
elements in your list X to your list Y
so that is the basic of matplotlib
there's a lot more you can do with it
you can change the look of the graph
you can change the colors the font so
much more but here we'll just explore
the basics and you can go ahead further
and experiment with this now the last
and the final library or the package
that we'll be looking at is the
scikit-learn package so what is the
scikit-learn library well it's one of
the most common libraries often used
with machine learning it provides a load
of algorithms so a lot of your machine
learning algorithms or the models are
actually already received within cycler
so you can just import these models and
they are readily available for use along
with that scikit-learn also provides a
lot of inbuilt datasets which you can
just import and use for testing and
training your models now that is exactly
what we'll be doing here we'll be
importing one of the already present
datasets so we'll use the random forest
algorithm train the
test it and then use a few predictions
so let's begin so start off with
importing your data set from SQL on so
you say from a scale on import data set
and today we will be using the IRS data
set now this is a very common data set
so it basically predicts a flower or it
categorizes a flower into Sentosa
versicolor
and virginica based on various features
such as the sepal length the settled
width the petal length and so on so
we'll have a better look at the data set
the target and the feature attributes
now once you have imported the data sets
library you just say data sets dot load
IDs and store the data set into this
variable iris let's run this line here
so now that we have a data set let's
look at the target variables of the sera
set so just say print iris dot target
names now when you using the data sets
which are already present in SQL are
it's much simpler to view the target and
the feature names because it's already
split in such a way of course if you're
importing a data set from outside or
you're importing an external data set
then you cannot directly say target
names you have to give the column
numbers so that the algorithm first
understands which exactly is the target
and which are the features but in here
things are much more simplified for us
so as you can see you guys these are the
target names all your flowers are
categorized as either setosa versicolor
or virginica next thing we look at the
feature names so iris dot feature names
so these are your features based on
which the flowers are categorized the
sepal length the sepal width the petal
length and petal width now let's look at
the actual data so right now we are just
exploring a dataset looking at the
various things before we move on to
actually building our model so that's
our data the first one here is sepal
length sepal width petal length petal
width so these are your values for the
features now let's see what exactly are
the values for the target so again say
iris dot target so that's how your
targets are the Z
basically represent the Sentosa and once
she present versicolor to represents
virginica so now we are done with
exploring a dataset so let's move on to
actually processing this and then we
will build a model train it test it and
finally predict it so we start off with
assigning all the data that is all the
values of a features to a variable X and
all the target values to a variable Y
now the point of separating these occurs
when you're training your model you need
to tell the model that these are my
features and this is what my target is
then again when you are testing the
model you need to provide at first only
the features so that it's able so that
you can compare it against your target
variables and see how your models
performing so all this might seem a
little confusing right now you'll better
understand as we go through the code ok
so now that our data split into x and y
next we need to actually split this into
the Train and the test data so for that
so we'll start off by importing the
Train test split method again this is
also present in Escalon so that US
importing the chain Thai split now let's
move on to actually splitting our data
see train test split we pass x and y
then you need to pass the size of your
test data so this is variable you can
give it whatever size you like but it's
always preferable to keep your test size
smaller than your actual training size
because obviously you need much more
data to train your model then to test
how it's performing and this ratio is
often 70 to 30 or you can say 75 to 25
in here we'll keep it a 7230 ratio give
my test size a 0.3 that's pretty much it
now the thing is this function returns
four values now the first value that it
returns is the portion for training from
the X data set so you say X underscore
train so this is basically the remaining
0.7% of the data but only the columns
which contain the features 3x
test which is the 30% of the data but
again just the features now we'll move
on to the y part the Y is the target
variable so Y underscore trail which
will be using for training a model and y
underscore test which will be used in
the testing phase to see how well our
model actually is performing currently
so those are the four values that will
be returned by the change' split make a
small correction here it's from not
import so now we are ready to run our
code and looks like we have all the data
within our four variables since it did
not produce an error so the next step is
to build the model but in our case
thanks to this particular library we do
not actually have to build the model we
only need to import it and then train it
so let's do that so we'll be using the
random forest classifier first step
import it let's now create an object of
this so we say CLF equal to random
forest classifier and now we need to
pass an argument which is an estimator
so this is very specific to random
forest an estimator is basically the
number of trees that will be created in
your forest so I am giving 100 so there
will be hundred cheese in my particular
forest and now that we have a model
we'll just fit X train and Y train to
this and this one line here will train
your model so now let's run these two
lines of code so as you can see guys
that's a model random forest classifier
and our model is also trained now what
we do is we will test a model so to test
the model we'll just pass our features
from the X test variable so X this
basically contains the 30% of the data
but only the features so 30% of the data
minus the target values so let's provide
this data to our model and see if it can
predict the corresponding target values
okay so to do this create a variable Y
thread here as in the predictions of the
values for y and say CL f dot predict
pass
it's test here now let's check out what
are these values within white credit so
these are the values which are predicted
by a model based on the input given to
the model so how accurate are they well
now how do these match up against the
actual values so all you have to do is
print out white test to see how it
matches up against the actual values of
Y and wealth so it seems like
everything's alright now to be sure or
to see how accurate our model is we'll
import this other library metrics and in
here we'll say metrics dot accuracy
score Pass Y test and Y predict so when
you give normalize equal to true it
basically returns a number if normalized
is equal to false it will return a
fraction let's run these two pieces of
code now and when that is our accuracy
which is actually a very good accuracy
now in the real world when you're
actually building a model or you're
using some external data set do not
expect such a high accuracy the very
first time you actually have to tune
your model quite a lot to get something
this good but yeah so that is our basic
on scikit-learn so with that we come to
an end to our course on Python if you
have any doubts regarding this please
post them in the comment section below
and we'll definitely get back to you
also if you found this video helpful
please hit the like button and also
subscribe to our channel if you haven't
yet we have a lot more great videos
coming up for you so stay tuned and see
y'all next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here